Vice magazine just tried to air a really
sort of sympathetic puff piece about the
reintegration of sex offenders back into
society and the the way that this
documentary ended I think is tells you
the entire story
we all out here in this world
and we all got to make it happen it
ain't non-stopping me so like I'm very
confident
[Music]
after this interview a chief sent a
picture of his penis to our producer
laughs
oh man I love you've got the platitude I
I bet knowing Vice I bet they really did
try to to make a puff piece about these
poor put upon sex offenders you know
these guys Society failed them if only a
society if only this racist
bigoted oppressive country Society
hadn't failed them then they wouldn't be
rapists or whatever
and I I do think they probably sincerely
tried to make that documentary and then
they film it and it is broadly
sympathetic and then you just get that
punch line at the end moments after that
interview moments after he this man
recited those platitudes we're all here
man we got to get together you know and
just keep on doing it man whatever
uh he sent a photo of his genitals to
our producer
which reminds us that we need Prudence
okay
Prudence is a virtue that I keep coming
back to again and again and again
because the left has absolutely no
respect for the virtue of prudence and
many people on the right do not either
sometimes especially when I'm when I'm
discussing a political issue with the
more ideological people on the right the
more dogmatic doctrinal five bullet
points on the back of a napkin Manifesto
type of people on the right they'll say
Michael you need I I want to hear the
principled ideological argument for why
we should ban marijuana but not tobacco
let's I'm just using an example or I I
want to hear the ideological principled
rationalist argument for why we
shouldn't have gay marriage or Michael I
want to hear whatever and I I say you
know
I don't need to give you I I think I
could in many cases but I don't think
that I need to be able to give you this
perfect modern
rationalistic kind of argument for for
my entire political program in society
I think we could we can use some
Prudence I remember when I was a student
I got to meet Anton and Scalia someone
asked him about gun control because they
said you know Justice Scalia you you
support the Second Amendment but you
think there are some limits here and I'm
not sure that the limits totally jive
with the original understanding of the
second amendment in the Constitution and
I don't understand why some guns can be
banned and other guns are not banned and
how would you determine exactly where
that line is
on the the limits of the Second
Amendment and scalia's answer has stuck
with me and I apply it to so many other
issues he said
how would I determine where the line is
on the Second Amendment
very carefully
this this answer infuriated the
ideologues and on certainly on the left
but on the right as well
but that's obviously the right answer
how do we determine
these sorts of limits in society how do
we determine when to show Mercy to
prisoners and and when to insist upon a
little bit more Justice when to go
lighter and let them out of prison and
reintegrate them into society and say
forget the past and when to put some
guard rails around these people how do
you do that
very carefully
you do it how do we deter why can't
lizzo play the flute lizzo if you oppose
lizzo playing the
sexist how do you would
a some other concert flout just to play
that flute yes I probably would but you
won't allow lizzo correct I don't think
lizzo should play the flute
well well why because I look at lizzo
and she's wearing a weird little leotard
thing and she's jiggling around half
naked and she's she's just behaving in a
way that's not not dignified
it's actually obscene whereas the
concert flautist wearing the white tie
and Tails is behaving in a way that is
dignified and so if I'm talking about a
national artifact from the from the
father of the Constitution I don't want
that to be degraded by being played
while a woman Jiggles around on stage
well but how Define dignity Michael defy
an obscenity Michael no I don't have to
do that I don't have to do it because
Justice Potter Stewart actually was
correct when he said yes it is a little
tricky to to Define obscenity
but you know it when you see it
you do we can do that we have the right
to do that in this country okay whether
the libs want to admit it or not
we have the right to use our use our
Prudence use our wisdom of repugnance to
use a phrase from the bioethicist Leon
Cass and just say you know like I can't
totally there was there was an article
that came out last week it said
why are gay same-sex
well I I guess those are the same thing
why are same-sex incestuous
relationships wrong
there's no possibility of procreation
there
so that bioethical consideration is off
the table so why is it wrong
you know I could give you a a pithy
enough explanation
but before I before I even would be
tempted to do that
because it just is because it just is
because we all know
deep down in our stomachs that that is
repugnant we have a prejudice against
that and that prejudice is good
Prejudice is not always bad Prejudice is
how we all survive
you don't want to be mean or unjust or
unfair but you certainly
we we have to rely on prejudices and
Instinct and and received wisdom
or we we wouldn't be able to do a damn
thing in the world if we had to write a
fleshed out rationalist
post-enlightenment treat us for
everything that we do all day long we
would never be able to do anything at
all
how do we
why do we put a lot of safeguards around
sex sex offenders even after they leave
prison well because we know that there's
a there's a real risk that they will
re-offend now is the time for the member
block okay the rest of the show is
continuing now we moved woke Wednesday
to Thursday because I was on the road so
we've got a video from The New York
Times I have not seen it yet I have been
told this even by New York Times
standards is really really
horrific so I can't wait that'll be
great if you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member head on over click
the link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]